[Musica]
[Applauso]
immaginate di essere in africa
il vento caldo sul vostro viso
l'odore della terra rossa
e la natura potente a perdita d'occhio
siete in africa siete in viaggio lungo
la terra rossa
ed ora allungate la vostra mano e
prendete dolcemente quella di chi è
accanto a voi
senza paura
prendetela e stringete la forte
l'ha sentita è quella sensazione di
iniziale imbarazzo
il battito che inizia accelerare
continuate stringete la forte
entrate in contatto con chi è accanto a
voi
l'ho sentito il calore
ed ora per favore
aprite gli occhi e lasciate che sia io a
portarvi in africa ma non perdete quella
sensazione di calore vi servirà per
capire come ha rivoluzionato la mia vita
è come forse rivoluzionerà la vostra
questo è un po ma una tipica casa
africana fatta di fi a mango e sterco
questa foto l'ho scattata nel 2018 in
occasione della mia prima missione in
africa avevo da poco concluso gli studi
e di intraprendere la classica carriera
da ingegneria ambientale
non avevo assolutamente voglia volevo
sporcarmi le mani volevo sentirmi utile
ma non sapevo come fare poi un giorno la
mia università pubblica un bando una
fondazione privata metteva a
disposizione
1.500 euro per chiunque volesse andare
in africa a condurre un progetto legato
all'acqua era per me dovevo
assolutamente inviare la mia candidatura
il problema però è che non è un progetto
in africa così decisi di chiamare tutte
le leggi italiane
e chiedere di partecipare gratuitamente
a un loro progetto
ma era una richiesta un po insolita per
un profilo tecnico ma a me non
interessava
io volevo partire e mi sarei mantenuta
con i pochi soldi della borsa di studio
e così dopo alcuni mesi ero in africa ad
occuparmi di un progetto di
potabilizzazione in 30 villaggi remoti
in tanzania
l'africa non era esattamente come me
l'aspettavo era dura complessa ea tratti
poco sicura ma quella fu una delle
esperienze più rivoluzionarie e
soprattutto più necessarie di tutta la
mia vita nello specifico mi occupavo di
valutare lo stato dell'arte dei sistemi
idrici e proporre la soluzione di
potabilizzazione più idonea e
soprattutto meno impattante dal punto di
vista sia ambientale che sociale
ecco vi ho parlato di sistemi idrici ma
la verità è questa la verità è che in
africa non c'era altro che una piccola
fontanella
il problema non era dove fosse posta
all'interno del villaggio
il problema era ogni quanto arrivava
l'acqua per quante ore al giorno alla
settimana o addirittura al mese
la situazione era davvero complicata
donne e bambini percorrevano chilometri
e chilometri sotto al sole cocente
semplicemente per raccogliere qualche
litro d'acqua
gli stessi che ne utilizziamo per
lavarci i denti o per farci una doccia
ad ogni villaggio che visitavo mi
rendevo conto che non potevo fare molto
era un problema endemico molto più
grande di me poi per un giorno successe
qualcosa di inaspettato
come tutte le mattine sali in macchina
per raggiungere uno dei trenta villaggi
del villaggio del progetto
quel giorno il più lontano lungo la
strada solo alberi e qualche casa
nessuna donna con la tanica sulla testa
nessun bambino che giocava nulla non
capire il motivo ma mi bastò arrivare al
villaggio per comprendere tutto
quattro mesi
quattro lunghissimi mesi che l'acqua non
arrivava al villaggio nessuna tubatura
funzionante solo un piccolo laghetto
neanche troppo pulito per bere la
situazione era talmente complicata che
il capo villaggio si lanciò in un gesto
un po inconsueto in africa è usanza
quando si arriva all'interno di un
villaggio entrare nel bosman quella casa
che vi ho fatto vedere prima salutare il
capovillaggio presentarsi e raccontare
perché si è lì e io feci esattamente la
stessa cosa entrai mi presentai
raccontare perché fossili e saluta il
capo villaggio e all'improvviso lo vidi
venire verso di me prendermi le mani
stringer mele implorarmi con gli occhi
lucidi di far giungere acqua al loro
villaggio ecco in quel momento io provai
la stessa sensazione che avete provato
un attimo fa non seppe rispondere era
commossa emozionata feci semplicemente
cenno di sì con la testa e ho fatto una
promessa avrei fatto giungere acqua loro
villaggio e così in una frazione di
secondo in un villaggio remoto
dell'africa scoprì la mia missione
mettere le mie competenze a disposizione
delle comunità locali
ecco perché avevo desiderato così tanto
andare in africa dove svelare a me
stessa la mia missione
ora sapevo a cosa avrei dedicato tutto
il resto della mia vita
ovviamente poi quel giorno tornare al
compound e parlai col capo progetto
raccontai della difficile situazione in
cui versava il villaggio
ecco non fu semplice trovare le risorse
in africa l'emergenza è all'ordine del
giorno ma io ho fatto una promessa non
mi sarei arresa fin quando non l'avessi
mantenuta
e così dopo alcune settimane
ritorna in quel villaggio sistemammo
tutte le conduttore e riportammo acqua
all'intera popolazione
ecco quello fu uno dei momenti più
emozionanti di tutta la missione
africana
avevo mantenuto la mia promessa quello
che non sapevo e che sarebbe stata
soltanto la prima di una lunga serie
africa sud america sud est asiatico per
anni ho viaggiato da un capo all'altro
del mondo realizzare progetti con le
comunità locali
esperienze tutti diverse e contesti
variegati accomunati però da un unico
punto di partenza
ascoltare la popolazione locale e
costruire con loro un progetto davvero
efficace in perù ad esempio una
associazione locale mi aveva lanciato
una sfida ideare degli itinerari di
turismo sostenibile a due passi da machu
picchu proprio lì dove il turismo di
massa si esprime con maggiore forza e
soprattutto lì dove gli impatti del
turismo sono più visibili sia
sull'ambiente che sulle comunità locali
ma come si fa a realizzare un progetto
di turismo sostenibile
beh si possono delineare delle politiche
di sostenibilità calarle dall'alto e
sperare che la popolazione le accolga in
realtà non è una soluzione efficace anzi
non lo è quasi mai
l'unica vera soluzione quella
rivoluzionaria e coinvolgere la
popolazione in tutte le fasi progettuali
e costruire con loro un progetto
veramente importante
e così che feci incontri continui con la
popolazione per ascoltare i loro bisogni
e training per sensibilizzarli
sull'importanza
dell'identità culturale e della
biodiversità
un lungo percorso fatto di ascolto e di
sensibilizzazione prima ancora che di co
progettazione ed è così che sono nati i
primi generali di turismo sostenibile a
due passi da machu picchu quella però fu
solo la prima esperienza del sud america
lei alicia leader indigena deiva urani i
valloni sono l'ultima popolazione dei
contattati nella foresta dell'ecuador
l'ho incontrata mera nel cuore della
foresta amazzonica
poco dopo
quelle che furono le proteste contro il
caro benzina e il furto della terra ad
opera delle grandi multinazionali
ecco quello fu un momento veramente
molto intenso toccare con mano la
deforestazione sentire il gas bruciare e
l'area di venire irrespirabile mikasa
voltò in una realtà che si conosceva ma
che non avevo mai visto da vicino
ecco era tutto lì dinanzi a me l'effetto
del cambiamento climatico la perdita
della biodiversità
l'impatto sulle comunità locali
a un certo punto mi resi conto che ogni
piccolo gesto quello individuale
era davvero inutile e fu in quel momento
che però conobbi un'associazione in
realtà io ero andata lì proprio per
questo condurre degli audit di
sostenibilità e valutare l'impatto di
alcuni progetti sull'ambiente e sulle
comunità locali nello specifico andai a
valutare l'impatto di progetti di
recupero della salvaguardia e
salvaguardia della fauna selvatica
e quel fu nel lavoro instancabile
dietologi e biologi che quotidianamente
contrastano e contrastavano quella che
effettivamente il commercio illegale che
ritrovai tutta la mia speranza fu quella
per me una lezione molto molto
importante ma in realtà non follonica
nello specifico la foresta amazzonica
con la sua saggezza e la sua immensità
insegna una cosa essenziale
non possiamo evitare di lasciare
impronte ma possiamo scegliere come
farlo ecco è questo che guida
esattamente tutta la mia vita non c'è
nessun gesto umano che effettivamente
non generi un impatto anche il semplice
fatto di essere qui in questo momento
tutti in teatro genera un impatto nei
rifiuti che produciamo nell'energia che
utilizziamo o banalmente nell'acqua che
consumiamo
ecco non abbiamo il potere di annullare
questo impatto ma paradossalmente
abbiamo un potere ancor più grande
scegliere quale impatto vogliamo
vogliamo generare
ecco scegliere di ridurre i consumi o
scegliere di utilizzare la nostra voce
proprio per trasmettere messaggi
positivi e un modo per generale impatto
ovviamente quello positivo ecco se con
questo mio spiccio oggi sarò riuscita a
far vibrare le corde della vostra anima
e generali un impatto positivo
ecco che quello di cui parlavamo prima
si trasformerà in qualcosa di bello che
come un effetto domino genere altra
bellezza
non so se avete mai visto il film un
sogno per domani quello con kevin spacey
e helen hunt chi non l'ha visto mi
perdonerà per lo spoiler lui e trevor un
bambino molto intelligente dal passato
difficile
in che modo possiamo cambiare il mondo
questa è la domanda che il maestro 2 nei
suoi alunni e trevor senza pensarci due
volte va alla lavagna e propone la sua
soluzione
passa il favore è una soluzione molto
semplice ma potentissima e ve la
racconterò usando le sue parole questo
sono io e questi sono tre persone alle
quali darò il mio aiuto ma deve essere
una cosa molto importante una cosa che
non sanno fare da soli per cui io la
farò per loro e loro la faranno per
altre tre persone
capite una cosa che aumenta velocemente
una cosa veramente molto molto potente
ecco se ci penso esattamente quello che
ho fatto anche io in realtà però senza
rendermene conto
bene nello specifico per anni ho
viaggiato soprattutto al sud del mondo
realizzando progetti con la comunità
locale in generale con la popolazione e
man mano che andavo avanti però mi
rendevo conto che non mi bastava c'erano
migliaia di progetti che avrei voluto
realizzare e soprattutto migliaia di
persone che avrei voluto supportare ma
per quanto lavorassi ininterrottamente
non ce la facevo non mi bastava
e così decisi di aprire un mio canale
instagram una sorta di diario di viaggio
ecco che le raccontavo tutto quello che
vedevo in giro per il mondo per cui ogni
storia che ascoltavo ogni persona che
incontravo o banalmente ogni luogo che
visitavo diventavano una finestra è
un'occasione per raccontare qual cosina
chi mi seguiva e così la community pian
piano cresceva sempre più persone e
sempre più interessate raccontavo della
deforestazione della situazione delle
donne in africa o ancora della
spiritualità nel sud est asiatico
e così pian piano a questo mio modo di
raccontare il mondo
ho iniziato ad aggiungere anche un altro
format il green corner
sessanta secondi per semplificare dei
concetti complessi un video di 60
secondi per parlare di climate change
sostenibilità ambientale impatto sulle
comunità locali turismo sostenibile una
sorta di passa il favore come direbbe
trevor un modo per generare un impatto
positivo
ecco viaggiare tanto in giro per il
mondo mi aveva permesso di capire una
cosa se vogliamo veramente generare un
impatto che passa che parta dal basso
dobbiamo dare alla popolazione gli
strumenti per agire in prima persona
empowerment educazione sviluppo dobbiamo
essere in grado di generare un circolo
positivo virtuoso che ci porti lontano
ecco che è nata farò la mia start up ad
alto impatto che ha un solo obiettivo
trasformare il turismo in una forza
positiva per cambiare il mondo
ma è un'idea semplice quanto ambiziosa e
se ognuno di noi viaggiando potesse
generare un impatto positivo
sull'ambiente e sulle comunità locali
ecco sembra impossibile ma non lo è
scegliere un alloggio gestito dalla
popolazione locale e non un albergo di
proprietà di un tour operator estero è
un modo per generare impatto o scegliere
di non visitare gli do mani come il
villaggio nel triangolo tra thailandia
laos e myanmar ma supportare delle
associazioni che realizzano progetti con
la comunità locale che un modo per
generare impatto o ancora scegliere di
non utilizzare prodotti plastici ma a
ricorrere a soli prodotti solidi proprio
per non generare i rifiuti
ecco è un modo per generare impatto non
possiamo evitare di lasciare impronte ma
possiamo scegliere come farlo e adesso
prima di concludere vorrei fare una
piccola cosa con voi un'ultima scegliete
una persona
mettetevi di fronte a lei
guardatela negli occhi e prendete le le
mani
provate a tornare
delicatamente nella nostra africa
lo sentite il calore il battito che
inizia accelerare eco ritornate in
africa
pensate a ciò che di più bello fate
nella vostra vita
pensate al motivo per cui siete su
questa terra
pensate alla vostra missione
quale favore volete passare grazie
davvero
[Applauso]